welcome back to CBS this morning in
their first u.s. television interview
two former Amazon employees say they
were fired for their activism on behalf
of Amazon warehouse workers Amazon has
faced growing questions about possible
retaliation against employees who speak
out about safety conditions amid the
pandemic on 60 minutes Sunday an Amazon
senior vice-president said the company
has quote zero tolerance for retaliation
but the two longtime Amazon employees
say that's exactly what ended their
careers with the company
Amazon's greatest fear is workers coming
together workers organizing workers
talking to each other and workers
speaking up together
that's why Emily and I were fired Morin
Costas says she used to love working for
Amazon helping the e-commerce giant
design everything from the homepage to
physical stores but last month after 15
years with the company she and fellow
designer
Emily Cunningham were fired after
calling attention to working conditions
at Amazon warehouses do you personally
feel like you were silenced or they
attempted to silence you absolutely we
were absolutely silenced the corona
virus has killed at least four Amazon
warehouse employees and infected others
we need fueling protests across the
country warehouse workers reached out to
us because of how unsafe they felt in
warehouses and how afraid they felt not
only for their own health but for their
families and for the larger public as
well and what was the reality you were
hearing from the workers themselves
Amazon's internal message to all of the
frontline workers the warehouse workers
they are heroes and we're doing
everything we can and everything is just
going swimmingly well it wasn't going
swimmingly for them at all
Casta and Cunningham say the pandemic
has exposed how Amazon treats its
warehouse workers differently than it
treats tech workers especially those on
the company's main campus when we found
one case of Co vid on the entire campus
chemist was shut down and everybody was
sent home when warehouse workers stay
home for fear of the corona virus they
just send
after the coronavirus hit Kosta and
Cunningham circulated a petition to
improve the lives of warehouse workers
asking for increased hazard pay and
additional safety procedures
I see listen to your workers listen to
what they're saying
back in 2018 Kosta and Cunningham had
helped create the group Amazon employees
for climate justice and they say Amazon
warned them against publicly criticizing
the company but it still surprised them
when on April 10th after their group
invited colleagues to a talk about
warehouse workers safety they got a call
from management I got an invite from my
director at 2:45 for a three o'clock a
meeting and I thought that was unusual
but at that time about three o'clock I
noticed I didn't have access to the
network anymore
and then about an hour later I got a
call from an HR representative who
basically told me that I had violated
multiple policies and that I was
terminated they say they were told
they'd violated internal policies among
them one that prohibits soliciting
donations from fellow employees my son
was actually in the adjoining room when
the call came in and so he just happened
to hear the whole thing you were fired
in a zum call like this that's correct
I took the call and it was very brief
you know my 15 years was ended about 30
second literally a 30 second phone call
last week nine US senators wrote a
letter to Amazon raising the question of
retaliation for whistleblowing
specifically naming Kosta and Cunningham
on 60 minutes Sunday Amazon head of
operations Dave Clark said the company
does not strike back at its own
employees well I can tell you we have a
zero-tolerance policy for retaliate
against people or for any number of
issues I've been here 21 years and I've
never seen anybody fired for complaining
or raising a concern what would you say
to somebody who's been following your
story and they think look a company is
like a family
you broke the trust we know the
importance of pilots being able to speak
up a Boeing engineer
years of nurses speaking up on behalf of
their patients and if workers are not
able to speak up it's a disaster not
only for those workers or their patients
or customers but for the larger public
as well and of course we did ask Amazon
for an interview the company declined
but in a statement the company said
quote we terminated these employees not
for talking publicly about working
conditions or safety but for repeatedly
violating internal policies as for the
safety of the workers Amazon says it now
is spending 800 million dollars on
safety measures and on top of that the
company identifies workers who come in
contact with a sick colleague and sends
those workers into quarantine with pay I
think the bigger question here Gayle and
Anthony is when we deem a worker
essential what does that mean in terms
of pay and protections that's a question
amazon has to answer and many other
companies across the country have to
answer and it's going to continue as a
conversation long after these employees
clean out their offices at Amazon Gayle
yeah both of those women I think Tony
raised some very troubling issues I only
hope that Amazon reconsiders its
position about not giving an interview I
don't think a statement really suffice
is based on what they raised also coming
on the heels of the 60 minutes piece
where they did have an executive talk I
hope they'll I hope they'll reconsider
their their offer to you that they will
take you up on your offer rather Anthony
yeah yeah no and and I mean to Tony's
point I think this is something every
company is gonna have to confront as
people start going back to work what are
actually safe conditions at least for
the next year it's it's a huge obstacle
to getting the economy back on its feet